hello everyone it's time for part 10 of
my resident evil playthrough
i really did get spooked by this sign
huh
i just really don't like it when
when video games do that you know oh
also
i think now i can go open this
get some [ __ ] poultry um
i'm expecting something terrible to
happen
it's making me very nervous
it's cool but i hate it um so that's
where we're at already
i don't who built this to keep these
chickens in here
were they really like should i be scared
heading into this situation are these
chickens about to
eat me why did you need to put
a mechanical crank gate on your [ __ ]
chicken pen
it just seems a bit excessive we don't
need to use the pipe bomb that's also a
bit excessive
oh my god things are messy
i do want to try the magnum but what i
figured i'm gonna do is uh because i
thought that the juke would have a
better weapon for me
you know what i'm saying we're gonna
sell our old shotgun even though i do
love it
i'll miss it dearly i didn't even do
what i was meant to do i keep [ __ ]
doing that i get distracted
shortcuts all right chickens
let me crouch do your real game hours
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up oh is that what it is
could be good poultry
yellow quartz no it's just regular
poultry
excuse me okay anything in here
no all right what's the ladder for
huh
what's this
what oh interesting
is that something
i think it's just the sun that's what
this video game's done to me
oh cool okay
neat i will take whatever you are thank
you
pigeon blood ruby oh yes of course
everybody's favorite
and then can i jump over there slash
would i even want to
no no i think we're good i imagine that
was all i was supposed to do here we
could try
and that's it what's all this blood what
is that
always here
okay um
i get that you want me to go that way
but i want to go see the duke
so i'm not going to go that way i'm
sorry buddy
it's not it's not happening today i got
weapon [ __ ] i need to figure out i got
[ __ ] to sell
i'm sorry that was gonna trigger a
cutscene seems like we're okay
all right take my arm flask
please it's the arms of my daughter it's
all
extremely normal cool
thank you okay great it's a cute little
save situation
i'm annoyed at myself for not having
more saves at the start i just kept
saving over the same spot and i'm pissed
off at me
something changed my apology i don't
think so
um all right king let me sell some
[ __ ]
sell that yellow quartz
so that yellow sound like crystal beast
i miss you buddy i'm sorry about what
happened to you sell that
sell that oh my god i'm about to [ __ ]
have so much money
okay this is lord morose
i suppose it's what they sure is beauty
of the grotesque
okay
i would like some health increases but i
need one more piece of meat i've already
done all the poultry ones maybe
just those two left huh thank you
i don't think i have any fish i can
hardly wait just excuse me a moment
cool we've done it my god
i did this so inefficiently
apologies for the wait here's your share
thank you
um okay awesome i wouldn't mind having
that again what else needs fish
this and i think that's it
i'm still upset with myself for using
the guard one first
i've
oh my god the power level on that magnum
holy [ __ ]
on level one dude
damn okay
i don't feel like i'm just gonna buy
this you know just because
[Music]
we're gonna do this that's amazing and i
have fully leveled up that shotgun right
yeah so she ready to sell but i think i
have some bullets in
it right now
which one is it it is this one right
look salmon no that's the new one
examine
you my good sir i have one bullet in you
i could sell it it's fine ah yes yes
yes yes of course yes i'm skilled at all
sorts of weapons modifications and we'll
do them for a small fee
good to know mate good to know i still
don't have a wonderful adventure
people on the internet also keep telling
me to sell this shotgun but i kind of
think they're wrong
let me show you why um
and for the record when people kept
telling me i was wrong and i disagreed i
looked up guides that tend to agree with
me
that this shotgun i like it better than
the other one because of the ammo
capacity and it has better handling than
this shotgun
um which means if i were to get rid of
one of them it would be that one but it
has a higher power level
but then someone was like yeah but if
you have more ammo capacity on the
second one then
it's better overall because it does more
damage but it actually also still takes
two bullets to kill virtually everything
with both shotguns
i don't know i really [ __ ] like the
shotgun man i don't want to get rid of
it
and now i'm wondering i feel like i
should keep the magnum
and a handgun because they're different
ammo types right
so here's what i'm going to do because i
don't want to get rid of the shotgun and
i don't feel like i need to yet
we're going to upgrade and then as soon
as i'm like
doing bad on money is when
we will reconsider things though i could
do ammo capacity on this just to see if
i can even get it
to where i want it to be um let's do
the magnum because that's really
expensive what
[ __ ] that is the reason for me to sell
the shotgun right but i really like it
i shouldn't pay attention to the
internet is the problem here but people
will be very upset with me
if i sell what they consider to be
the lesser shotgun um look if we do this
it does change that power rate
significantly okay
i understand that's reload speed 2.3
that's reload speed 2.2 the ammo
capacity is still higher eight is
fantastic
that one's 1.6 that one's 1.5 look
i think i am gonna sell you
so that i can upgrade other [ __ ] that is
what i'm going to do because that's
[ __ ] expensive i just want you all to
know that i don't feel good about it
and everyone who came at me for using
this shotgun that i prefer
is wrong it's a good shotgun
i like it a lot and i will miss it
dearly
securing goods is more important i'm
sorry buddy you served me so well
my friend
it's time to go i need that money
selecting your website but uh yeah i did
also have people be like why are you
upgrading the weaker shotgun they sell
more overall
they sell for more overall if you
upgrade them full list you should
upgrade everything to the fullest
regardless of using or not really um
okay we can upgrade our handgun
[Music]
i'm not super stressed about either of
those things on a handgun so we're gonna
go with
oh boy i like a faster rate of fire
and then we'll do reload speed
we can do all of them beautiful i'm
excited to try it out
um
can i avoid both okay cool
this simple modification can be done in
just a moment i'm sad
and i'm sorry that i just discarded my
beautiful
shotgun i don't feel great about it
i'm gonna do that because we like them
all right duke all right calm down fam
um
unfortunately you don't seem to have the
funds well that's because i pressed the
wrong button sir
done give me no mind i will pay you to
mine thank you thank you for your
patronage i'm just gonna keep a separate
save in case i regret everything that
i've done here severely
okay you have no ammo look at these
holes in my inventory and i don't like
them
i miss you
uh okay let's just [ __ ] do some
tetris work over here
and make sure that things are a little
bit more orderly this is a lot of
handgun ammo
not a magnum oops
okay yeah great beautiful oh yes good
just throw your [ __ ] shotgun over
here
that's good [ __ ] that is that is good
[ __ ]
yeah um
oh you know what i was gonna say
i was gonna say let's go to the
graveyard because it seems to want me to
go there at all times but now i realize
i can do this
how about that let's go do that and put
that away
i need to reorganize all this [ __ ] too
hang on okay you can now go to the top
you should go here
yeah i mean the handgun realistically
should actually probably be the one that
goes over there
but um i'm excited
should be a good time okay
i assume this is gonna be side content
um based on the fact that he was trying
to lead me
you can probably finish this game really
quickly if you aren't
spending time crying over the weapon
that you don't want to sell
i think that when i do finish the
playthrough i'll probably stream it and
see how fast i can get through it
just on the casual difficulty but not
that it's very hard on this difficulty
in any case i was actually surprised by
how easy the game
is um okay
wait wait i can't get back up to that
area
huh huh all right cool
yeah let's do boat stuff boats and hoes
not that i know where to go
okay oh that'll take me back up to there
well that's way further away than i
would have thought
all right let's do that cool let's go to
boat shop everybody it's gonna be a good
time
because there's a well in the in the
backyard there that i couldn't get oh
this feels awful
these boat controls are not good
it's uh it makes me think the last of us
part two they were very good in last
part two that was some good boating
just boating around with my bros i had a
great time
okay and we're gonna dock here then
all right cool great love that for me
okay interesting this has got to be an
area i haven't been to before right
where is this where i came out
no i haven't been there we will go to
the hut
first to go to the well
i'd be [ __ ] scared of these
drawbridges i feel like they are
old as [ __ ] and being that there is only
one crank in the entire town
probably not super reliable they could
absolutely jumpscare me through here
they [ __ ] they could
they don't you do it you son of a [ __ ]
appreciate that thank you okay this one
is the well wheel
what do you get
oh
oh do i want to do that or should i go
get that first that's what i think i
should do is go through that other door
that's
i didn't expect that um okay i'll be
back
i just want to check out this other door
real quick
that i'm pretty sure i never had access
to before now
okay i've been missing this castle
what do you think lady d is up to you
she's having a good time
okay interesting
it's another one of these
swingy over here thank you
oh i don't even mean to do that yeah i
mean yes very intentional
entirely intentional oh what the [ __ ]
hello mate i'm gonna try this on you see
how
see if we have a good time
i don't want to miss i'm gonna miss my
first shot with it you know
then what if there's one on the other
side too my bud can i light him in fire
that seems like a bigger priority
oh that was supposed to happen why was
that supposed to happen that was
definitely supposed to happen
why what do i need to light up on fire
for it has to be something
there's no way that they animated that
for an achievement
what do you need to be lit for can you
come like this
mate come over here
i need you to like this [ __ ] puzzle
design in this game is so good the fact
that
you're like hmm okay
there you go mate okay let's you're
gonna die or
maybe i still need him you leave me
alone
i feel you back there you little [ __ ]
but i need your help
don't leave me there might be other [ __ ]
i need you to light up fire fam
just give me a second nope no you don't
no you don't
let me get everything in here yes
i know very scary oh no well give me
another one did i waste too much time
mayhaps that was all i needed him for
my love light of my life
anything else magnum ammo
okay is that it cool that was that was
neat i like that a lot that's cool
puzzle
um okay glad i went there now let's go
back over
and go down the well not a thing i
expected i thought this would be a short
little boat ride
here we are here we [ __ ] off
somebody just make some kind of
monster-like noise
did you hear that correctly
there's a typewriter in here
now i'm having too many save slots
i'll remember that we've come so far you
know is there anything in here probably
not this is clear
we're fine okay
don't love this not what i expected
all right
i need chapstick just can you just wait
a second ethan that's gonna be pretty
annoying to do
do i have chapstick sitting here
somewhere surely i've got some
i was hiding behind my coffee give me a
second everybody just ethan just stay
there stay where you are please
you got to get that grip strength down
anyway now that your wife's dead
that was a good joke
um yeah i'm happy with that one
okay
all right this is going to be terrible i
think and also i'm not sure if it's a
side quest or if this is
what the [ __ ] oh no
oh oh my
i
hate this a lot actually
um okay
well uh you're gonna make me do some
kind of
death puzzle in here how do i
interact with anything you need me to
shoot stuff there's nothing
yellow all right calm down please i what
okay i hear you um oh my gosh
um
oh my god wow this is a death chamber
can i just climb it oh oh
okay well i overthought that one that's
my bad i really expected that this would
just let me sort of
uh move things up and down or something
why did you give me that though
what's why is that oh god oh here it is
my mind interesting okay i'm
just trying to get over there or is
there [ __ ] for me to
loot um
just make them all green oh
for now and see what happens is there
anything
okay i can push this for some reason
hmm
not sure
why exactly you probably want me to move
that off is what i need to do
right okay
that is going to require moving that
back down
let me move this one down so i can get
down two
right
yeah i know it's locked from the other
side oh um
this one has to be from behind so i need
to do something with the one that's at
the top
first you can't be moved any further
interesting love's a puzzle okay
um let's move that one back up then
just to see what i can do with this
particular cart
i don't believe that you can't be pushed
further ahead there we go
okay so let me just move that one back
up i think for now
push it off
i'm right or push it on
get out of here
beautiful
um and then
that is down there
oh maybe i can climb up here
right hang on
and then i want to climb this way ah
interesting i wasn't sure if it would
let me do that cool
that could have taken a very long time
to figure out um
all right great
yes thank you don't mind if i do who's
making these [ __ ] animal rubies
what sicko is [ __ ] with any of this
um is that everything no
my my but there's more
[Music]
i don't love that uh have i [ __ ]
missed something in here
this is gonna be my [ __ ]
one red room
you son of a [ __ ] it is
there's probably something up there that
i didn't get
no i will not be bested
i can't get back up
garbage no
did i miss like ammo up there or some
[ __ ] ah
oh my god i'm upset you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wow i'm just gonna pray that there's
something down here that i've missed
the worst video game i've ever played in
my entire life i cannot [ __ ] believe
you
holy [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] up this is this is [ __ ]
up
i bet you i missed like
if it if it's one of those [ __ ] shiny
things there's no way of me to know when
i'm in this stupid room oh my god i'm so
upset
[ __ ] hell resident evil
you maybe it'll reset you know hey okay
we'll just come back
is this it ah
is that was that it surely it wasn't it
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you are a piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
video game
oh my god no
okay i'm just gonna push it from my mind
it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine i didn't i
had no way of knowing that that would
oh my god
it's now this whole game is gonna like
i'm gonna have like a scratch
but maybe it'll reset when i come back
at some point
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you're dead to me capcom every one of
you is dead to me
never again swear to god
it's just this is upsetting all right
take this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
cap call me [ __ ] boat
zero out of ten ass boat zero out of ten
ass video game
oh my god it's dark um up the other way
of the river i guess
let's do that shall we my mind
tally hurt i'm dead on the inside i just
want you all to know that
that i am crying um
this is you know i'm locked in a hotel
room for 14 days straight and i don't
have fresh air and i haven't been able
to breathe properly because i'm an
asthmatic
and this is still worse than that
this is worse than every breakup i've
ever been through this is um
yeah capcom really really
punched me in the face and gave me a
wedgie
and then like made my head flush in a
toilet or whatever it is that the
kids do when they mean to bully other
kids where the [ __ ] am i
huh okay rocks scared me
no oh my oh no
what have i gotten myself into here
what's uh well
that seems like it
could be bad actually great
cool what's all this
dna sequencing complete 99.95 percent
match to
dolby mutable seat the deviation of 0.05
can presumably be attributed to
artificial changes by humans which means
this is probably the source further
investigation
into how the connections manage to find
and extract the mold as needed
the fungal colony is spread out under
the entire village when you take
the baker incident into account there it
is
uh the hosts of the muta my seat are
part of a network of
consciousnesses if that network is
linked to here then we could assume this
organism here
is data storage if that's the case then
what data is miranda after
i was expecting that
oh my god what the [ __ ] have i walked
into
okay
great uh what's happened here
um
cool this is terrible what the [ __ ]
no oh my god no i'm sorry everyone give
me a second
i gotta oh this is why do i have too
much ammo
it's not a thing you want a resident
evil game oh my god it's
awful okay i'm gonna have to redo some
[ __ ]
i can't put the explosives out here
you know grab these this is our little
explosive corner
of course i just want to like waste
bullets now because this is the worst
thing i've ever seen in my life
jesus okay um
just based on it being fancy magna memo
gets its own little
capacity as well um i'm gonna move the
knife up
this down and our little lockpick friend
can go right here
the lockpick should go here
i need to move these over it's so very
important you understand
that will do okay
um
i'm very uncomfortable with the amount
of
firepower i just got
oh my god okay
oh all right magnum okay
we won sean boyce these days all right
what the [ __ ] happened out here
is it like an end what the [ __ ]
oh my god
okay if you [ __ ] say so resident evil
all right jesus what the [ __ ]
uh magnum's great pleased to report
magnus great i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is
should i flashbang it i don't think that
this is intended to be a fight
but also i want to
just to see what happens
you know what i'm saying
how do i tell which one's which okay
it's gonna be lt and a
this one's a flashbang and then should
we just sort of
wow okay well
um have a good one mate uh i'll see you
around
sometimes really nice to meet you um
anyway the baker connection made me
assume that that's why ethan is so
um laughably op in any case
because i feel like that's intentional
and has been done because of the time
he spent in new orleans or whatever the
[ __ ]
um is there any way to go this way
before we
had to do [ __ ] fish jump scares again
lads get dead this is a hard part of the
game ladies and gentlemen
you know what i hate fish is
uh okay i don't know who that was um
brilliant you know what this yellow
chord is
you know what happened here let me let
me let
me tell you about video games ladies and
gentlemen this
was a level design issue they
noticed that players were not getting
into this water
um so they made the fish jump and added
this yellow cable
because uh yellow is the way that
resident evil signifies that you need to
go somewhere but that's what was
happening here was people were like no
pond
and they were leaving so they had to put
in uh
more obvious cues it's um the amount of
game studios that i've been to they
obviously work at one now but
um where hang on hang on it seems like
i've gotten everything
that there is there's everywhere yep
yes so i've been everywhere is what i
was trying to say
[ __ ] that room though just i've been
everywhere
except for like this one part like here
or whatever the [ __ ]
no i don't even know where it is anymore
but he's [ __ ] dead to me
what's that noise
um the stuff that players miss that like
people think they're so good at video
games until they play one that hasn't
been
crafted with perfect perfect design that
is designed to tell them absolutely
everything that they're supposed to do
and everywhere they're supposed to go
here's the real secret every game's on
easy mode
because people have meticulously crafted
them to make sure that you know what
you're doing
okay i feel so sad without
my shotgun but it's fine
the internet bullied me into doing it
and also i knew i would have to
eventually
for inventory reasons but i think i made
the right choice when seeing how much
stronger this one gets in the end
but i'm still pretty upset about it
hey bud i got some [ __ ] to sell yes yeah
and some fish
huh no meat
no yes
[ __ ] don't let up yet
ooh movement speed that one sounds fun i
would like to have that
um i think i have some garbage i can
sell you you can have my blood ruby
combinable
wait a minute did i [ __ ] up
why are you clapping at me sir did i
just sell something i shouldn't have
sold
oh no i did
i shouldn't have sold the other welcome
ruby ah
damn i can't buy stuff back can i
damn
that's a real shame
i was wondering if they'd be like a buy
back area [ __ ]
damn it well i really [ __ ] up this
playthrough
today's episode's a bad one
this is what happens when i uh play and
right before napping
i feel like i need to sell this now
that's very upsetting we can get rid of
that
and get rid of that
splendid you know it's work
you hate to see it i think i'm just
gonna keep it
just in case maybe i'm wrong but i'm
pretty sure i made a mistake
um okay we can do some crafting i do
know how to mine
how to cross mines now so we'll do it
just to have it done just to have had
done it
shotgun flashbang
and i guess a mine then good deal
cool if i say so myself yeah well i'm
[ __ ] upset dude
maybe if i like need to go do that for
achievements or something i'll do it at
some other point
um all right don't feel great about
going back to the graveyard do feel good
about having the magnum to do it with
the
very creepy um everything's lock picked
right
yep uh i'm sitting further back so let
me just adjust my camera real quick
it's alt and then no wait that's the
wrong button it's alt
and then nope that's there we go
beautiful look at me go
okay oh
gentlemen
okay that's all right actually i
i'm really sorry about nope
you attack me i don't feel as bad about
it wow
you really came right for me
i'm trying not to waste ammo so if we
could just you just want to come to me
we just get this over with
that would be great
okay but there you [ __ ] all right i
was expecting there to be like enemies
in here for some reason
i suppose not let me go give meat to the
duke i'm [ __ ] upset dude this one
part 10 is a real doozy i sold something
i shouldn't have
and i didn't get a [ __ ] item so
welcome
this is just a bunch of hot trash uh
what do i have i have meat
this one will be done thank you now to
cook
hell yeah sweet
great i'm getting towards the end of the
game huh
because i only have one lord left anyway
here it is beautiful please
join me okay
such a dish could be had in this winter
boundary and this one only needs one
meat
damage tango and gaudy godly i don't i'm
not
guarding so i don't i mean i [ __ ] it i'm
just trying to finish them at this point
right
now let's do this one first
we've gathered all the ingredients
stunt
it is slightly zelda-esque for cooking
sounds
here it is please why thank you ethan
doesn't eat very much
if we're being honest not a bad dish
i agree wearing goods is more important
than i can upgrade that i couldn't
afford
no do you have magnum ammo
you do not have magnamela
or really anything else that i care
about buying
don't care about the scopes range you
can take another pipe bomb
what's what's funny dude we'll take
shotgun ammo
and we'll take another first aid man
shut up
have a wonderful adventure i didn't give
you that if it's just looking window
shop away no i have some meat to give
you
if you know what i mean
that one will be done now we just need
one more fish
jeez thank you cool how to cook
i really should god that said i've died
what twice this whole game
once here it is please join me
i don't even know if i've died twice
i've not died very much so i don't
really know that guarding is important
i'm sure on
a harder difficulty it's something that
you have to use more often but again
i have not died very much in this video
game you have
really at all okay
just moving stuff around don't worry
about it i should have
[ __ ] just moved magnum over just
because
and then we're good to go
have an eye for quality thanks mate
uh hang on safe you should save real
quick still [ __ ] upset about that
necklace
goddamn room okay
let's do it let's finish the game i
don't imagine i'm gonna finish it right
now
i imagine there's gonna be another part
or so
i hate this this is
the show must go on okay well i do like
a
a video game that uh gives me game show
vibes that's always a fun time
so maybe it'll maybe it'll just be like
a fun game show it's gonna be a really
fun time
okay
i still don't have that achievement for
the crows
okay thank you i appreciate that
anything over here
to look at all maybe
oh they're supposed to go through the
mine
well hang on can i open that
i might be able to i should check that
hmm okay i'll edit this out because
i know you guys don't need to see me
just running back to [ __ ] clear the
map out
but i think it might have had a key on
it
and it's you know it's really me playing
this as though
everyone who's watching this playthrough
is sitting in the room with me
rather than as though i'm trying to
entertain any of you i'm sorry about
that
what what
who who's that
somebody just made that [ __ ] noise
okay can't do that um
[Music]
somebody out here trying to stop some
[ __ ]
maybe
or was the game just doing the thing
where
it made a sound for no reason who the
[ __ ] is out here
oh he's big okay
i didn't come back here for this let's
do
that the flashbangs aren't gonna [ __ ]
help you here alana
hello is he bigger than the other ones
hello large lad he's got he's got like
poles in him
oh my okay
[ __ ] let's do it then let's jam [ __ ]
come on you don't know where i am
okay great the magnum is called wolf
spade
oh my god you are large i'm missing all
my shots
okay i'm gonna just run a bit right here
i'm just gonna
climb over that i'm just gonna run for a
bit
he's gonna be hard to run from it's
gonna it's gonna be tough to run from
this one
i think baby it's not a great idea i
want to get inside this [ __ ] house
alana you went the wrong way to get
inside the house where the [ __ ] have you
gone
okay mate
okay no bad call bad there's bad calls
across the board trying to get inside
the house because i figure he can't get
in houses okay
he's big um hang on let me properly
and then just when we go to lta
flashbang's really not going to do that
much though this is only got two shots
left
all right i'm all right with it
have you gone mate
what king
all right i feel like i should be able
to see there you are okay
maybe we pull the sniper out as well
instead of no oh
instead of the knife in this situation i
think
it's [ __ ] strong but i know that
again
using flashbangs instead of
having access to he's like afraid of the
house oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i missed the door okay [ __ ] come on
oh big boy he's big he's scary
come on come on
yeah yeah is that it
we do it oh my god wow i didn't expect
that when i walked back here
okay cool i did a bad job in that fight
but we made it out okay
we've just blown all our [ __ ] magnum
ammo
um which i don't love
but uh glad i came back glad we walked
back around
that's i never would have known
what you know there's like no reason to
even ever go back to that area
unless it takes you there at some point
later but you could miss that fight
entirely
what did i come back for oh to see if
that thing was locked and they heard him
that's right
maybe that is the reason you go back
there maybe that unlocks later and that
would
cause you to go back there all right
mate you wish to make a purchase
yes i wish to sell you the
crystallized ancient beast the [ __ ]
i'm gonna sell it
because i [ __ ] up i'm just gonna sell
it it's fine
excuse me mistakes for me yeah can't do
any of that you used to be alive
i missed you baby i miss you so much are
you so beautiful
i don't care about it
i guess you know i've got so much money
and also yes because i just used one
good day then
i didn't mean to do that but it's fine i
gotta heal
all right back we go
fix my [ __ ] loadout um
i still i'm gonna put that
just back there because i'm used to it
being there
we'll put the magnum there shotgun is
still over here right yeah okay
that's how it's gonna have to be i think
and then we'll go find our mate
back up here i really was not expecting
that this is what
exciting times so is that the first
fight we've been in this whole time oh
no there were those dudes in the caves
we got [ __ ] up by magnum so so fast it
wasn't even like a fight
all right the fact that you seem to want
me to go that way just makes me not want
to go that way is my
thing so no i'm going this way and i'll
find out in due time if it's a mistake
hmm why are there explosives on the
river
i wonder i wonder why on earth those
would be there
otto's mill you say
okay maybe this is separate to the other
areas
in some way can i cross the stream yes
interesting this is actually a pretty
big area
get out of here go
fine we can shoot you i don't what do i
care rolling in ammo out here
you think there are any fish in this
stream because i just need one fish
again resident evil circumstances i did
not expect
oh no it would tell me there are no fish
confirmed no fish
all right why the explosives though
is still my question
all right
there's a beast in here
where are you king
am i gonna get another animal jump scare
it wouldn't be the first time
that's interesting music
i'm sorry mate thanks for the meat
though
you're a real g
okay
hmm otto's mill huh
cool
uh well that's a i wasn't expecting that
um
okay
all right
this all seems fine okay
great
hello otto you're a big boy
can i kill him from here
uh we're gonna get rid of the magnum
because it has no helmet really
you're gonna flashbang and snipe my dude
which means i
am jumping between these two i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to fight him
though
no i don't think i can
i think that uh all of this
all these explosives are here for a
reason hey mate
right i'm not really sure though cool
[ __ ] accident dude
okay okay okay okay yep
you're grumpy i see that can you get
through here
[ __ ] the sniper's out i shoulda bought
more have so much money
um well then
what are we going to do here other than
organize our inventory
inventory inventory in the middle of a
fight
my my i don't know that i should do this
yet maybe
you know but then what i have just done
is a waste [ __ ] it let's just
if i die i die i should do that with it
buddy mate big boy
large man or do i need to lure him out
let me try the other side of the house
because again there's all these
explosives everywhere
which makes it seem to me like i'm
supposed to do explosive business on a
man
unsure
all right
[ __ ] you
can we loot it out somehow surely
hmm i'm too scared to explore how
is my problem all right big dick thank
you that king
what kind of ammo i'll take that mate
where the [ __ ] did he go oh
oh oh
oh that's interesting
is that smaller mates coming through
he's guarding there that's what it looks
like
can you jump down
[Music]
i just need to reload i'll be back in a
second just give me a minute
it's a fair fight i don't know what
you're talking about
i also just need to get rid of the
[ __ ]
i could just use that you know just the
one
it's very strong
okay
boss good guy
all right oh you're up again you're up
again
i think it's happening thinking i'm
still not [ __ ] sure
because of the sparks you know
you want to stay stuck there that would
actually help me a fair amount
it's pretty good for me actually
see that
i just missed that shot
are you invincible sir
is this not the way to do this fight
[ __ ]
all right
oh okay i'm doing it wrong and i'm
wasting
all of my [ __ ] ammo so here's what
i'm gonna do break that open
took a bit of a risk there i understand
that
and see what other options
i might maybe have okay explosive rounds
are definitely gonna help
did you [ __ ] off dude
all right big boy oh oh my okay
that'll scrap great not 100 what i was
off though
just give me a second please uh we're
gonna come back with this
i've still got it equipped okay so i
just need to where are you
my big my big friend my big handsome boy
and then we're gonna ltn a and we're
gonna do this
you know what i'm saying he is
[ __ ] strong one more
oh my god
is that it holy [ __ ]
that better be worth a lot for the
amount
and what were all the explosives for
was i supposed to get you outside i'm
still not entirely sure about that
there's [ __ ] treasure here somewhere
though oh and there's more stuff in here
[ __ ] hell that dude
was tough
maybe that this is where i was supposed
to get him to go or something
gee oh oh well hello
okay [ __ ] sake man
oh i don't love this
this is a lot of meat
today's the day jolly merchant stops by
you always gives me old newspapers i
know miranda forbids them but news of
the outside world is always so
fascinating there was that one thing
that piqued my interest in the last one
it was an article about some medicine
company i don't remember the name of the
emblem look familiar
checks out it was the same symbol on the
giants chalice i'm pretty sure i saw the
same one painted on the walls in the
cave too
that radiating umbrella image really
stands out what's some outside of
company emblem doing here i wonder if it
had anything to do with that man that
stayed here all those years ago
interesting the implication being that
uh they turned him into a giant the [ __ ]
was that
what the [ __ ] was that what
the [ __ ] okay well i have everything
that's in here
hello don't mind if i do
it's a lot of stuff you're giving me
that
should actually make up for all the [ __ ]
that i just [ __ ] lost in that
goddamn fight all right i'm gonna go
back
here
and just see what i missed in here i
suppose
it's just it's fine that's allowed to
move alana it's getting all synthy up
here it's
strange okay
so many explosives that i did not
[ __ ] use
ah okay well that's that done
i suppose um
we're gonna
head back to
the duke again oh hello eight
not really equipped for this am i
okay
should be it i love being wasteful with
my handgun
uh the only weapon that i have any ammo
for left i'm just like
just throw it away
i need it desperately right now it's the
reality
all right back to my big duke boy i
think i'm gonna be able to level up
no i think i'm missing oh no i'm not i
was gonna say i thought i was missing
one fish but i think that he had the
fish
frankly that did just sort of seem like
he was having a good time
and i just killed him and he was just
hanging out in this mill
i probably didn't you know maybe that
was a bit mean
maybe i didn't need to do that all right
mate yeah i got some more [ __ ] for you
just to make a purchase
nah mostly wish to make you cook me
stuff
thank you wait do i actually have more
meat than i
need or does he get more recipes maybe
i have too much meat finished
love for you to enjoy as well thank you
wait i didn't make it for you
i wouldn't mind having that again
uh okay yep
yep i have so much [ __ ] meat dude
um all right let's sell this [ __ ]
you still got nothing new anyway here of
course not i'm flies
we're just gonna buy all the ammo that
we can
which is almost going to be entirely
sniper rifle right now
buy a couple more of these that's the
last one
sure just because i feel so under
equipped right now
um what am i supposed to do with this
[ __ ] meat
i worry that if i get rid of it that i
would be
wasting something i might need to use
later
i don't know man i don't know
i feel like they're all done
so i feel like i should just sell them
he's never added any
meat at any other point it just seems so
weird to have too much meat okay we'll
just keep it because i have room for it
and then we can deal with it later
[ __ ] ammo the
[ __ ] dude wearing a bad spot here
it's not good
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
this is the worst episode of this whole
thing
because i've lost everything
um i'm just sad really i'm just sad um
look at all these [ __ ] zeros
jesus
may the handgun serve me well
all right put that up there
put that up there i think i should leave
this one here
um not what i expected i expected us to
like fully go and do all the heisenberg
[ __ ] but
we didn't um man
this is the worst [ __ ] day of my life